so more evidence comes out that former
president trump was indeed trying to
pressure the doj to overturn the 2020
election specifically the binding
administration has released notes of a
december 27 meeting between former
president trump and
then acting attorney general jeffrey
rosen as well as assistant deputy
attorney general richard donahue the
notes
and this goes under the heading of real
lawyers take notes the notes indicate
that trump was going through his whole
litany of insane
election conspiracy theories to which
rosen and donahue pushed back
saying that they couldn't do the things
that he wanted them to
to which former president trump replied
he didn't expect them to do it
but he said specifically just say that
the election was corrupt and leave the
rest to me and the r
congressman and we lawyers call that a
zelinski maneuver just
announce that there's an investigation
or things are corrupt without any
evidence whatsoever and then hope you
can
make hay out of it so maybe that's good
for your own personal purposes but it's
not good for the rule of law so we'll
see if this ends up in court